[Music]
come away with me
if i don't get out of here for a while
nuts i love you so much
it's just the three of us just you and
me and ella daddy because you're old
you'll die before mommy right hey
not that old it's so
beautiful i love this
wait what listen
quiet
i know it's fun but it's time to sleep
goodnight honey
jesus you got enough switches
[Music]
does this wall look right to you what
are you doing
26 feet 21. this room
is five feet longer on the inside than
it is on the outside
how does that work it doesn't
anything happened yet
[Music]
you chose this place not me you sent me
the link i absolutely did not
you sent it to me
somebody wrote in my journal
do you like it here
no do you i hate it
[Music]
hello
are you okay
what is this place there was a different
house before that one
what sort of house why do people hate
daddy so much
the judge and the jury all found too
innocent but some people didn't believe
him
the house shows me he must be guilty of
something
people have always stayed in that house
the right ones usually find the place
or maybe it's the other way around the
place finds them
you